[Music]
it goes without saying that the scp
foundation has a storied history with
ancient anomalous groups of interest
from the metal-worshipping mechanites to
the fire-loving brazen heart to even the
brutal empire of the slave owning deva
who swear allegiance to the dreaded
scarlet king but perhaps the most
dangerous and downright disgusting of
these groups are the flesh-worshipping
disease-loving body-warping sarcists the
sarcists believe in returning humanity
to a nightmarish primordial state they
utilize anomalies to achieve this goal
such as the horrible
scp-610 also known as the flesh that
hates a disease that converts human
beings into mindless beasts of twisted
flesh driven to spread their disease
further and further the sarcists were
once a world superpower controlling much
of modern-day russia and eastern europe
from the holy capital of atitum a city
ahead of its time with towering
blood-red temples wide winding roads and
the castle of grand karcist ion an
immense blistering red and gold
structure that was as beautiful as it
was imposing it would only make sense
that the former area of the sarkic
empire would host some of the most
ghastly of the sarkic anomalies it
should not be forgotten that while the
sarcists are a group of interest for the
scp foundation they are first and
foremost a religion one with ancient
practices of blood and human sacrifice
while the scp foundation is famed for
its containment procedures when it comes
to the likes of actual deity entities
containment isn't quite as
straightforward the standard put it in a
box until it stops trying to get out
technique just won't cut it the deities
require specific practices that
sometimes go against the core values of
secure contain protect take
scp-2845 for example this entity known
as the deer is a being that requires an
intense deadly and specific ritual to
keep it properly contained the scp
foundation even had to outsource help in
containing this anomaly anomalies such
as these placed the scp foundation at a
crossroads of action or inaction when
this issue is combined with a sarkic
anomaly that could bring catastrophic
results should containment fail they
need to make the difficult choice of
letting the anomaly stay where it is
without intervention for the safety of
the world this nightmare started in the
year 1916
during the battle of transylvania of the
first world war as bullets flew and the
smell of smoke pervaded the noses of the
scared soldiers bloodlusting beasts were
waiting their time to strike staking
behind the unnaturally curved trunks of
the trees that lived in the nearby hoya
forest soldiers armed with weapons and
tactical armor were quickly and brutally
attacked and consumed by entities that
would become known as the pale men
at the time not much was known about
these pale men and they were believed to
be a myth among the local populace meant
to scare invading soldiers from stepping
on romanian land but when 244 people go
randomly missing in a single night with
no obvious signs of death no bodies ever
being found and reports of pale men
dashing through trenches and within the
surrounding hoya forest the scp
foundation would surely have to
intervene this would not occur until
1919 however as world war 1 raged on
diverting foundation attention away from
these mysterious deaths agents frederick
harper and rhys gorman posing as
military officials and local law
enforcement began to speak with the
locals around the hoya forest and the
surviving soldiers while shellshock
rocked the soldiers with guilt and
terror gorman was able to ascertain that
the soldier's stories of the pale men
were too consistent to be a falsehood
created out of stress the pale men were
described as living vampires more bat
than human and deadly fast appearing in
quick flashes before dragging the
unsuspecting victims to their untimely
deaths within the hoya forest meanwhile
agent gorman spoke with members of a
village within the hoya forest near the
battle site their demeanor was cold
which was expected he was an outsider
speaking rudimentary romanian in an
obviously foreign tongue the village
people claimed ignorance declaring that
they had never heard stories of pale men
and did not subscribe to fairy tales
gorman realizing he was unwanted nearly
cut his losses before the elder of the
village stopped him this elder an old
man draped in hand-knit scarves and red
silks invited the agent into his home
and gave him the truth
these villagers were followers of
sarkicism the home of the elder was
decorated with sarkic glyphs and
paintings detailing the stories of
yaldabaoth the primary god of the
sarcists battling meccan the legendary
broken god on a lectern sat scrolls and
dusty tomes detailing sarcic history
from former kings to stories of battles
that were waged against the mechanites
and devites the elder explained that
there was a sarkic god within the hoya
forest known as the mother who sends out
her children to feed and help her grow
even larger the village worshiped the
mother and tried their best to keep her
at bay by conducting ritual sacrifices
to her and her brood however the advent
of world war one led to difficulties in
containing their rituals as they were
living in an active war zone and the
mother's children and their hunger were
impossible to control leading to the
unfortunate deaths of the soldiers agent
gorman was eventually able to convince
the elder to show them where the mother
resided a temple superficially
resembling other eastern orthodox
monasteries but this was no house of god
that you or i would recognize on the
lower level it contained an ancient
beast
starving for blood and sacrifice this
place soon became designated
scp-2191 otherwise known as the dracula
factory new containment procedures were
quickly enacted 20 armed guards were
placed around the temple with strict
orders to dispatch any entity that exits
the structure standard containment
procedures for anomalous buildings were
enacted as well preventing all
non-foundation personnel from entering
scp-2191
and authorizing the use of lethal force
when necessary access to
scp-2191 has allowed foundation
biologists to research the entities that
were known as the pale men these
creatures were found to be genetically
human but with a variety of alterations
that should have resulted in fatalities
these entities were subsequently
designated scp-2191-1
scp-2191-1 entities appear to be more
bad than human with large conical ears
that end in sharp tips upturned noses
and the ability to communicate via echo
location this echolocation ability comes
in handy as
scp-2191-1 are completely blind their
eyes have recessed into their skulls and
a layer of skin has grown over them the
entities also lack pigmentation leaving
them starkey pale appearing to be made
more of porcelain than flesh or bone
these entities are predators solely
hunting living human beings ignoring
human cadavers or any non-human animal
they hunt by spreading through the hoya
forest and chasing their victims once
caught
scp-2191 entities will inject their
victims with a paralytic agent by
stabbing them with a sharp bone that has
grown from their wrists they will then
unhinge their jaws allowing a leech-like
entity to exit their mouths and begin
the feeding process by latching onto the
victim's neck this leech designated as
scp-2191-2
will first inject the body with
digestive enzymes converting organ
muscle and bone into liquid before
consuming the resulting fluids the
feeding process can last anywhere from
20 to 50 minutes depending on the size
of its prey these are highly skilled and
sophisticated predators and while they
lack the higher intelligence of
non-anomalous humans they make up for it
in ruthless ferocity it would only make
sense that the foundation would enact
strict containment procedures to avoid
the loss of human life but while these
containment methods worked for a time a
series of anomalous events connected to
scp-2191
transpired over the next 70 years the
first event was in late september of
1932. the iresos earthquake devastated
the chokadiki peninsula of greece
leaving houses crumbled civilians
homeless and causing 490 reported
casualties surveys of the damage
conducted by the greek government found
that 126 people who lived in the
affected areas could not be accounted
for the question now arises where are
these missing people seven years later
in 1939 this time in turkey the arzinken
earthquake struck the country resulting
in the catastrophic deaths of
approximately 33 000 people among the
survivors reports of a great serpent
were given from all who witnessed the
event the foundation then intervened
posing as members of an international
disaster recovery agency reports from
the locals remained the same a great
serpent a deep red and black in color
and incomprehensively massive casting
dark shadow miles long rose from the
ground at the onset of the earthquake
and writhed in the air as the earth
shook for a period of three years
nothing related to
scp-2191 transpired and the foundation
believed that the anomaly had gone
dormant that was until an earthquake
struck varanza romania in 1940 while
casualties were low compared to the
earthquake in turkey reports from local
survivors have repeated claims that pale
men attacked the fleeing people as the
earthquake occurred chasing after them
and tackling them never to be seen again
with a large-scale event like this and
potential witnesses to anomalous beings
the scp foundation was risking a broken
masquerade scenario should the
information spread broken masquerade
scenarios are considered an xk class
scenario by the scp foundation and as
such they employed a media blackout and
that newspapers state that the witnesses
of these vampire attacks were nothing
but superstition in march 1953 in turkey
the yennes going earthquake led to the
deaths of over 1 000 people the
foundation once again posing as members
of an international disaster recovery
agency interviewed survivors and
attempted to find any connection to the
preceding events reports from survivors
again told a consistent story they
witnessed the arm of a blood-red octopus
rupture from the earth when the quake
began behaving similar to the great
serpent writhing in the sky and reported
that pale men were seen attacking
survivors in the night as they searched
for places to sleep these sightings of
pale men persisted for over a month
after the earthquake before amnestics
could be distributed another event
occurred in march of 1977 in romania it
was a similar story to all the others
with over 1500 civilians dying as a
result of the vorancia earthquake and
800 civilians being declared missing
foundation officials embedded in the
romanian government were told that
reports of pale men and tendrils pulling
victims beneath the ground begin to
surface leading to media blackouts and
amnestic distribution as panic spread
throughout the region the foundation
couldn't figure out what was causing
these events when they began instituting
the containment procedures around
scp-2191
no
scp-2191-1 entities were able to exit
the temple without being quickly
dispatched so how were these events
occurring especially in areas so far
away from the hoya forest could it be
that the large creature seen breaching
the earth was responsible the foundation
decided to return to the village that
originally told them about the temple to
interview their elder once more dr
judith lowe was given permission to
conduct the interview she was a senior
employee of the scp foundation and had
multiple doctorates in sarkic history
and psychic anthropology her expertise
and the subject was unmatched dr lowe
had written multiple studies on the
sarkic culture and understood the only
thing that satiates sarkic gods blood
with this knowledge in mind dr lowe met
with dragan negrescu the current elder
of the village draga was an old woman
wrapped in the red silks and scarves as
the previous elder dr lowe began to
interview and jumped immediately into
the subject asking draga what she could
tell her about the temple draga replied
stating that the temple was home of what
they called the mother the mother was
not unlike a queen bee as she sends her
drones out to collect blood much like
bees collect nectar braga continued
stating that her village acted as the
beekeepers to the mother helping the
hive flourish and stay full before the
scp foundation intervened thraga
expressed that it was imperative that
they would be allowed to continue their
sacred duty of satiating the mother dr
lo needed more information on who
exactly the mother was draga negrescu
told her that the mother was once a
princess and the daughter of a sarkic
blood empress in eritum the ancient
sarkic capital she was a strikingly
beautiful girl wearing the finest of
clothes and had long dark red
her as his own she became his mistress
while she first hated her position she
slowly grew to worship grand karcist ion
as a god while grand carciss ion is seen
as a deity now it was not during his
reign as the king of the sarkic empire
the princess begged to bear ion's
children as a result she was blessed by
the grand karcist and was planted in the
khoya forest to grow large and wide ion
commanded the princess to bear as many
children as she could muster and she did
the princess birthed ions children the
pale ones for all of eternity and would
let them feed as ion would want draga
stated that she and her village are no
different than the pale men as they were
tasked with keeping the mother fed and
satisfied draga then let slip this
chilling remark the mother and the land
are now one
her earth and womb swells
and soon
she will rupture all around you his
tinder for the gods
it seems as though the foundation's
containment efforts led to the deadly
earthquakes and deaths of thousands of
people by stopping the practices of this
village to contain the mother through
ritual they had potentially caused an xk
class end of the world scenario one
question remained though
where is the mother an investigation
into the tunnel system located below
scp-2191 would lead to the answer mobile
task force units that specialized in
underground exploration such as the mole
rats were sent to the tunnel system
below the temple armed with weapons to
dispatch any loose
scp-2191-1 entities these agents
discovered a grisly sight a massive
writhing mass below scp-2191
researchers believing draga's story
ascertained that this was the mother and
designated it as scp-2191-3
this entity is a massive blood-red
organism buried deep beneath the earth
where scp-21
stands the true size of the entity has
proven entirely impossible to measure
but route-like appendages have been
found to extend throughout the tunnels
below the earth these appendages were
found to secrete a toxic highly
corrosive acid
scp-2191-3 uses this fluid to create
tunnels which explains the odd tunnels
below scp-2191-2
measurements place the area
scp-2191 spread to approximately 6 600
000 square kilometers under the balkan
peninsula
for comparison's sake scp-3000
the amnestic producing eel god and a
tashisha is a measly 900 kilometers in
length at maximum with that in mind now
we can see the gargantuan problem the
scp foundation is dealing with
scp-2191-3
is sapient meaning it has an innate
sense of understanding and
self-awareness and exerts control over
scp-2191-1
and
scp-2191-2 organisms via the release of
complex pheromones
scp-2191-1 entities act as feeder drones
for scp-2191-3
it has since been discovered that
civilians native to several isolated
villages in the vicinity of the hoya
forest have actively provided human
sacrifices for scp-2191
as a means of minimizing the seismic
activity that occurs when it is famished
and this worked to satiate the entity
and prevent further damage to the earth
and its people the foundation now stood
at the crossroad between active
containment and allowing the people who
knew and understood the anomaly to
contain it themselves the foundation
motto is secure contain protect however
if they allowed raga negrescu and her
village to continue their sacrifices
they will be unable to fulfill any of
these core values but
scp-2191 will not be wrecking havoc this
dilemma led to the involvement of the o5
council a joint statement from them
reads there are some who wish to believe
that the foundation has never nor will
ever cater to the designs and desires of
an anomalous entity foundation efforts
to contain scp-2191
are now thought to have inadvertently
led to the deaths of approximately 40
000 people over 45 years the obvious
choice would be to neutralize the threat
and we've tried the number of civilian
and foundation casualties being well
beyond acceptable numbers in order to
contain the larger threat we must allow
it to feed we are aware of the offense
caused by this procedure this is not the
first time nought will be the last that
the foundation has been forced to commit
a lesser evil in the prevention of a
greater one
we do believe that in the end our
current method is the most preferable
with regards to both ethics and
efficiency we are fully aware that every
sacrifice feeds
scp-2191-3 allowing it and its brood to
thrive but we are not about to sacrifice
the entire balkan peninsula to
neutralize that threat not yet it was
clear that the scp foundation had no
choice but to allow the villagers who
lived around scp-2191
and the mother to continue their
practices upon their involvement there
was catastrophe after catastrophe that
would only stop once the correct people
draga negrescu and her villagers could
return to their way of life and end this
madness a final containment procedure
was ordered as a result the scp
foundation would maintain surveillance
operations via the use of closed circuit
security cameras and drone footage all
personnel of the scp foundation would be
prohibited from directly interfering
with scp-2191
or the ritual practices of communities
within the vicinity of the hoya forest
which include blood or human sacrifices
to scp-2191
exploration of scp-2191 would only be
allowed by remote-controlled drones
lethal force is only authorized should
scp-2191
or any of the creatures that live
beneath it breach containment should the
foundation fail in upholding the ritual
practices that keep the mother at bay
well dragon negrescu said it does all
around them is tinder for the gods
now go check out
scp-2783 silent lamentations of a
clockwork goddess and
scp-1348 inner sanctum for more
fascinating anomalous locations